[Applause]
you must be devastated
that was actor john cryer on the hit cbs
sitcom two and a half men
uh crier now stars as lex luthor on the
cw super girl
and he's among the long list of
hollywood celebrities who have been
vocal critics
of our lame duck president cryer hit the
headlines on this particular issue after
a 2016 interview
when he compared trump to his former
co-star charlie sheen
hindsight is 2020 and crier's words
about a trump presidency
could not have been more prophetic
there is an interesting overlap between
uh
how yeah
charlie and donald trump i mean there's
an interesting people like
that he's willing to to just say
whatever foolishness comes to the top of
his
foolishness foolishness and uh and it
was it's fascinating to watch because
uh i i i i don't want people to pick the
president based on
entertainment value because i saw
somebody spectacularly flame out and
and ruin everything that was good in
their lives by doing that
and i don't want uh somebody else to
ruin everybody else's lives
yeah by coming to power that way
ruining everybody else's lives if only
tens of millions of americans had
listened to one out of the two and a
half men
this week the outgoing president granted
a series of controversial pardons and
john cryer
tweeted out this in response wow the
gang's all here he's pardoning members
of his criminal organization
his corrupt gop backers and a guy
involved in the massacre of 17 people
here to talk about all of that and more
is the actor himself star of a show
me and my kids love cw supergirl uh john
cry thanks for coming on the show
thank you so much for having me
john we're exactly four weeks away from
donald trump leaving
office how are you feeling right now as
someone who's been viscerally
opposed to him from the very beginning
someone who was fighting with trolls
last year on twitter
over the need to impeach him uh
well obviously i i feel grateful that
the nation has spoken uh and that they
largely understand uh how malignant
uh of course he's been in in office um
i i do think that that that you know
finally his popularity polls are
starting to slip it's like wow
is this all it took him actually losing
the presidency
um but uh you know i i
i i understand i understood even at the
time
people's impulse to give him a chance
you know um i i think hollywood had sold
them
this vision of this guy as a brilliant
billionaire
uh businessman and i think people said
yeah let's let him have it
have a shot um but obviously that was
not true it was always a
fiction that was created by hollywood
and
uh and people are right to be mad at
hollywood for voicing that on them
uh you know i think they're not wrong um
so you know i'm i'm hoping that yeah
that
you know because the the bs
engine that that propelled trump into
office
is sputtering somewhat lately that we
can have some sort of uh
reconciliation with what actually
occurred during his presidency
indeed i hope we do as well although the
the truth of the matter is not enough
people have been
uh blunt enough or honest enough about
just how bad trump
has been why i enjoy uh following you on
twitter is you're always very very
uh plain spoken about our currently
lamed up president and you haven't just
picked fights with trump
but also his enablers you had a row with
a very trumpy republican congressman
matt gates of florida on twitter after
you criticized him for bringing
a holocaust denier to the state of the
union he fired back with a tweet saying
charlie sheen carried two and a half men
as if being a co-star on a tv show is
worse than having
a white supremacist as your guest to the
state of the union uh the show of course
lasted long after charlie sheen's
departure
and as you pointed out to gates you even
won an emmy uh during that period
but john is it kind of bizarre for you
as an actor who's been around since the
80s and now here you are in 2020
going back and forth with a congressman
about your tv show we live in weird
times
we absolutely do um and and i you know
and i
stepped into you could see on that clip
from the reel i was stepping into
politics
very tentatively i don't you know i like
seeing entertainers
and just enjoying them for their
artistry and their work i love john
voight
i think he's a fantastic actor you know
uh uh i don't want to think about
the the the bizarre rants that he goes
on you know
i want to just enjoy the
um exactly so i get why people feel
sort of resentful towards celebrities
who are getting into politics
you know uh um uh they also perceive
that there's a power
imbalance and that's fair that's an
absolutely fair um
uh uh criticism that being said we're
also americans
uh and and when we see when i in
particular with trump because i could
see that
the entertainment media establishment
was being weaponized
um that i felt like okay i have to step
in and say something
at this point uh and matt gates is you
know he's a clown he
you know he doesn't even believe half
the stupidity he he spouts
you know he's that that's what
this is just a game to him i'm also
amazed because his head seems to get
larger
but his face seems to get smaller and i
don't know how that works
i don't either trump this week pardoned
a bunch of black water war criminals
you are someone who's known not just for
acting not just for slamming trump
but you've also been involved with the
undisclosed podcast about
wrongful convictions in america and
knowing what you know now about
non-violent offenders who are in prison
that must make trump pardoning war
criminals while leaving so many more
deserving people
behind bars even more frustrating for
you
uh yeah it's it's enraging i mean in
this particular case i actually that i
was in error somewhat on that
um uh uh on that tweet because because
he actually
pardoned four people who were involved
with the massacre of 17
people so uh um you know war crime these
these are war crimes that were
adjudicated this wasn't an argument that
they were saying oh
you know there was the prosecutors held
back evidence or anything there was no
procedural
reason to pardon these people there was
the the
the the reason was to just you know it's
it's a right-wing fever dream
that uh you know we we're you know these
people are
valiant warriors who got you know
crushed by the system or something
that's just not the case in this in this
particular incident
you know our criminal justice system you
know does
need uh um uh you know like any huge
bureaucracy it's it's
it's it's it's feeding on itself in many
ways uh
and and a lot of regular
human beings are being just eaten up by
it and thankfully the media
and and thankfully the undisclosed
podcast has brought a lot of these
stories to light and
and the narrative does appear to be
changing in the public
um in the public understanding yeah
and and based on what you learned
through doing that through hosting that
uh podcast series
how um how urgently do you think joe
biden should tackle
criminal justice reform how urgently do
you think he will tackle it
well it's tough because much of what
happens with wrongful convictions is
happening on a state level so the
federal government actually has
limited amounts of input
um and also a lot of it happens at a lot
of these stories when you get into the
nuts and bolts of them
happen on uh on just the level of police
misconduct
uh and the level of juries
misunderstanding
of how junk science that's being
presented in courts
um and the entertainment industry itself
has been portraying stories from the
point of view
of uh cops for forever
you know and that's and i love cops and
you know i i respect the work they do um
it's it's
it's scary work um but there as in any
huge government bureaucracy there's
people that do it well
and people that really don't uh and
uh and so you know the the the horror is
when
human beings fall through the cracks and
and are robbed of their lives
um and their families because of this
that that type of thing
so i i think the joe biden
administration has
so many things on its plate um in terms
of just
just bringing some basic accountability
to back to the federal government
that's going to be a huge uh you know a
huge challenge
then climate we got climate change
that's terrifying
you know uh so they've got so they've
got such
huge uh uh you know trump has left such
a mess
for for joe biden to clean up that um
you know i i i i
i it's on a state level
it's a horrible thing to have to inherit
for any new president before we run out
of time i do have to ask
about superman uh supergirl and superman
uh the two series on cw that are coming
in superman four you played lenny luther
which i didn't realize i had to think
back to that my childhood
the nephew alex luther now in supergirl
on cw
you're playing lex luthor himself what
does that be like now that's a journey
from nephew to the main
villain himself um that's been actually
incredibly satisfying for me way too
satisfying for uh frankly an adult i i
you know for a 14 year old boy uh it
would make total sense to get this much
uh
satisfaction out of it but i'm an adult
uh i really
i should not be geeking out as much as i
do um i love it i absolutely love it
i've loved the show i've had a great
time
um superman 4 was a bit of a misfire i
don't know if you recall it was the last
of the christopher reeves superman
movies
um it they it ended up being uh sort of
legendary
as in terms of a flop uh of how these uh
superhero movies can go because it
basically ended the superman
franchise so when they gave me a shot to
play lex luthor it was kind of my
chance to fix it to sort of fix the the
legacy
uh and uh and it's been amazing the fans
have been
incredible uh the supergirl fans i've
loved the writing on the show um
and but it is just uh you know
you can get away with everything that's
your supervillain that's what you do
and you do it so well um and we've
enjoyed watching you
uh don't worry those of us who are also
adults have been geeking out watching
you
geek out on screen uh it's been a
pleasure talking to you today john we're
out of time
uh but we really appreciate you coming
on the show happy holidays
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories thank you for watching